kroner lage worüber wir uns freuen dass
wir hier nach wie vor wöchentlich haben
und dazu unsere gäste begrüßen können
bevor ich dazu aber näher komme trotzdem
noch mal ein paar erläuterungen dazu was
die bundespressekonferenz ist wir sind
keine einrichtung der bundesregierung
sondern eine regierungsunabhängige
organisation ein verein den
journalistinnen und journalisten
angehören die in berlin über
bundespolitik berichten
wir veranstalten hier diese
pressekonferenzen führen selber darüber
regie und ermöglichen damit dass
mitglieder der bundespressekonferenz und
das war eines der auslandspresse hier
ihre fragen stellen können
seit der korona pandemie wissen wir
stoßen die auf ein großes öffentliches
interesse worüber wir uns grundsätzlich
natürlich freuen und freuen uns darüber
dass phoenix uns und eine
gebärdensprachdolmetscherin dafür zur
verfügung stellt die auf dem sender dort
zu sehen ist jetzt komme ich zu unseren
gästen herzlich willkommen
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
daneben den vize-präsidenten des rk ii
lars schaade und heute ist mit
dazugekommen der präsident des
paul-ehrlich-instituts klaus cichutek
alle drei werden kurze
eingangsstatements halten bevor sie zu
ihren fragen kommen und der minister
beginnt ja vielen herzlichen dank
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
für die möglichkeit einmal mehr die
lager heute einzuordnen eine lage die
weiter schwierig ist in manchen debatten
dieser tage mit der grund für die
maßnahme und die einschränkung ich finde
da könnte etwas mehr auch in den
mittelpunkt gestellt werden
denn wir haben weiterhin eine sehr
schwierige situation auf den
intensivstationen 19 patienten über 5000
wieder wir haben einige bundesländer und
regionen die auch schon wieder bei
strategische verlegungen nachdenken und
nachdenken müssen weil es zu regionalen
engpässen kommt ja es gibt kliniken in
deutschland wo relativ weniger belastung
ist und in klinik kiel beispielsweise in
einem bundesland mit relativ geringer
instituts aber es gibt auch sehr viele
kliniken und regionen in deutschland wo
die belastung sehr hoch ist und sie ist
vor allem auch sehr hoch fürs personal
das darf man nie vergessen die
pflegekräfte die ärztin und
alle dort beschäftigten sind seit über
sechs monaten in sehr sehr starker
belastung
wir haben das jetzt eine überlastung
vermeiden können in deutschland und
wollen das auch weiter tun und noch
jedenfalls in dieser phase der pandemie
ist es so dass ins events und intensiv
miteinander zusammenhängen weil es ja
immer eine diskussion gibt warum wir so
stark auf incidents werte abstellen noch
ist es so und das ist auch die erfahrung
der letzten monate und die erfahrungen
eigentlich allen ländern der welt sehr
extrem und schmerzhaft gerade in
brasilien zu erleben dass wenn die
inzidenz steigt in der folge auch die
belastung in den kliniken und in den
intensivstationen steigt das ist so
lange so dass wir ein sehr viel deutlich
größeren teil der bevölkerung haben
impfen können und wir sehen auch dass es
eben auch jüngere die im übrigen in
aller regel auch länger eine beatmung
und intensiv medizin brauchen dann
tatsächlich auf den intensivstationen
liegen also eine sehr starke belastung
wir haben jetzt zweimal geschafft in der
ersten und zweiten welle eine
überlastung zu vermeiden das sollte uns
jetzt auch in dieser dritten gelingen
die welle zu brechen eine überlastung zu
vermeiden
da ich wohl heißt es häufig ist ja alles
wie vor einem jahr ist er nichts neu
doch vieles neu und viel können wir auch
mehr als vor einem jahr wir wissen mehr
würden schützen über dieses virus und
wir wissen auch mehr und können auch
mehr
im umgang mit diesem virus und ich will
nur drei beispiele kurz nennen die
korona waren app über 27 millionen
nutzer jeden tag informieren 5000 über
5000 positiv getestete und informierte
ihre kontakte wir wissen aus umfragen
dass sie im schnitt 6 kontakte
informieren sind 30 bis 50.000 zweifel
ins mehr als 630 bis 50.000 die jeden
tag informiert werden über 13 millionen
labortest ergebnisse die direkt dann an
den endnutzer gegangen sind die cluster
erkennung die wir jetzt eingeführt haben
und die möglichkeit bald auch schnelle
testergebnisse und noch eine zeit später
aber dann auch das im zertifikat in der
app zu haben und die diskussion zu
anderen apps zeigt übrigens datenschutz
und daten
sicherheit ist nicht zwei nahles und das
ist jedenfalls weiterhin bei der caravan
app das qualitätsmerkmal das testen
haben sie schon mal gesagt über 15.000
teststationen die entstanden sind eine
infrastruktur die wir so vor drei oder
sechs monaten nicht hatten und natürlich
das impfen standorten morgen sind 18,5
millionen deutsche mindestens einmal
geimpft das in 22,2 prozent 7 prozent am
main vollen schutz mit einer zweite
impfung erhalten
gestern sind 600 6000 menschen geimpft
worden
damit ist mehr als jeder fünfte deutsche
geimpft es wird bis anfang mai jeder
vierte sein
im laufe des mais nach allem was wir
erwarten dürfen in den nächsten wochen
jedenfalls jeder dritte das macht es
möglich dass wir im mai die
priorisierung gruppe 3 auch öffnen
können einige bundesländer haben sogar
schon ja damit beginnen können termine
zu vergeben für diese gruppe und dass
wir im juni
weil ich heute einige präpositionen sind
wichtig nicht ab juni im juni nicht
erster juni soll dann im verlauf des
juni sich bitte das wirklich den
unterschied zu machen weil sonst
erwartungen entstehen
die nachher möglicherweise nicht erfüllt
werden und impfen im juni priorisierung
öffnen heißt nicht dass dann innerhalb
von einer woche wir gleich jedem einen
termin machen können auch das ist
wichtig für das erwartungsmanagement wir
werden im juni im juni die priorisierung
aufheben können nach den defa prognosen
die wir aktuell haben aber das heißt
nicht dass wir dann im juni schon alle
impfen können
sondern das wird natürlich dann auch bis
in den sommer hinein gehen müssen und
das finde ich sehr sehr wichtig dass
nochmal einzuordnen ich würde zu einer
meldung die mich heute morgen drei mal
im radio gehört habe auch noch was sagen
es lägen fünf millionen dosen irgendwo
auf lager das tun sie nicht mit den
impfungen von gestern sind etwa vier
millionen dosen im moment unfair impft
wenn ich alle lieferungen dieser woche
mit einbeziehen
die nächsten lieferungen erreichen die
impfzentren und erz praxen frühestens
montag dienstag das sind noch vier tage
in diesen vier tagen werden bis zu zwei
millionen dosen verimpft
das heißt wenn überhaupt etwas sozusagen
nicht verimpft ist binnen der nächsten
tage dann sind es zwei millionen
die in aller regel aber auch schon
termine im laufe der nächsten tage haben
und deswegen werbe ich dafür ja wir
hatten eine zeitlang die situation dass
es relativ größere mengen gab die noch
nicht verändert waren wir sind
mittlerweile aber in einer situation wo
das was ausgeliefert wird auch sehr sehr
schnell verkauft wird und das ist mir
noch mal wichtig zur einordnung
aber all das zeigt ja wir können mehr
als vor zwölf monaten
aber wir können diese welle nicht weg
digitalisieren wir können sie nicht weg
testen und wir können auch nicht gegen
sie ankämpfen
das zeigen übrigens auch die beispiele
testen österreich trotz vieler tests
auch sehr frühzeitig ist die welle nicht
konnte nicht vermieden werden
israel großbritannien konnte auch eine
hohe impfquote nicht vermeiden dass es
eine dritte welle und auch weitere
einschränkungen notwendigkeiten gibt und
deswegen geht es jetzt darum diese welle
zu brechen und das mittel der wahl das
wirksamste ist und bleibt das reduzieren
von kontakten
viele länder haben aber in der letzten
oder vorletzten woche gesagt niemand
muss auf ein bundesgesetz warten
die maßnahmen können auch vorher
ergriffen werden viele länder haben das
gemacht dafür bin ich dankbar
viele bürgerinnen und bürger haben nach
meiner wahrnehmung auch in der
persönlichen empirie im bekanntenkreis
aber auch das was wir durchaus ja in
mobilität und infektionszahlen in teilen
sehen auch im vorgriff auf die maßnahmen
ihr verhalten verändert das haben wir in
den letzten monaten häufig gesehen dass
auch eine wahrnehmung der situation und
der schwierigeren lage da ist und das
zur verhaltensänderung führt und
gleichzeitig tritt morgen dann die
bundes notbremse in kraft
die ja als notbremse wie der begriff
schon sagt idealerweise etwas ist wie
vorher auch schon gebremst wurde und
weitere maßnahmen gemacht wurden 35 50
er ins ident sind ja auch weiterhin im
infektionsschutzgesetz angelegt ist eine
konzentration auf drei bereiche
betriebliche kontexte weniger mobilität
wie home office mehr testen schule kita
verpflichtende tests regelungen für den
übergang im wechsel und distanz
unterricht und in die notbetreuung und
vor allem der bereich der privaten
kontakte und das ist das was am
schwersten fällt
weil das natürlich ein sehr starker
freiheits eingriff ist kontakt und
ausgangs beschränkung ich werde nur
sagen diese ausgangs beschränkungen
stehen seit anfang märz in einem
beschluss von bund und ländern im
instrumentenkasten für die institute
über 100 und wurden und werden jetzt
eben über gesetz umgesetzt das ist hart
es fällt schwer geben von uns aber es
ist für eine übergangszeit und das ist
ja das wichtige notwendig also geht es
darum jetzt die bälle zu brechen um dann
test gestützt öffnen zu können auch
deutlich mehr öffnen zu können weil wir
mehr testen können außengastronomie
theater einzelhandel fußball und der
einhaltung natürlich der weiteren
hygiene und abstandsregeln und damit
brücken zu bauen in die zeit im sommer
wenn wir tatsächlich dann nicht nur
allen für alle die priorisierung haben
aufheben können im ersten schritt
sondern vor allem dann im sommer auch
haben allen die wollen einen impf
angebot machen können und ich weiß im
sommer klingt im april noch weit weg
in einer zeit wie dieser aber in
wahrheit ist es nicht mehr so weit
es ist jetzt der letzte teil aber ein
sehr schwerer teil der zu gehen ist ja
sehr geehrte damen und herren die
fallzahlen scheinen im moment nicht mehr
so rasant anzusteigen
das ist erst mal eine gute nachricht die
bundesweite sieben tage instanz bewegt
sich seit einigen tagen etwas über 160
das und hat sich somit auf einem hohen
niveau eingependelt
einerseits haben einige länder in den
vergangenen wochen bereits die maßnahmen
verschärft aber dies könnte auch damit
zusammenhängen dass schulen und betriebe
über ostern geschlossen waren und dass
die mobilität geringer war
das können wir an unserem mobilitäts
daten sehen in den ersten zwei
aprilwochen st die bundesweite mobilität
über jeweils eine woche gemittelt von
minus zehn prozent im vergleich zu 2009
10 auf minus 20 prozent an einzelnen
tagen sogar auf minus 40 prozent dass es
ein recht starker effekt und würde über
die zeitliche verzögerung durch
infektionsverlauf und meldeweg auch zum
aktuellen platte der meldezahlen passen
wir sehen in die mobilität daten dass
viele personen zu ostern nicht verreist
sind und ihre mobilität eingeschränkt
haben wir sehen dass sie sich
eigenverantwortlich einschränken wenn
sie durch feiertage und ferien die
möglichkeit dazu haben dafür möchte ich
mich an dieser stelle bedanken
damit haben sie alle das virus etwas
gebremst die fallzahlen sind aber immer
noch auf einem zu hohen niveau
sie steigen nicht mehr was so massiv an
aber sie sind im moment leider auch noch
nicht
heute ist die sieben tages incidents
wieder leicht angestiegen und die
mobilität hat ab mitte april wieder auf
das niveau vom märz 2021 zugenommen für
entwarnung ist es also zu früh das
spiegelt sich nach wie vor auch in den
krankenhäusern wieder immer mehr cupid
19 patienten müssen im krankenhaus
behandelt werden
die zahlen steigen besonders bei den 35
bis 59 jährigen
auch die intensivstation fühlen sich
fast weiter in allen bundesländern und
fast allen bundesländern weiter über 80
prozent der patienten auf
intensivstationen benötigen eine
beratung besonders besorgniserregend ist
dass immer mehr patienten so schwer
erkranken dass sie sogar an eine ecke
behandlung die sogenannte künstliche
lunge müssen die extrem belastend ist
oft sind dies jüngere patienten leider
sehen wir auch dass die zahl der
todesfälle seit ende märz nicht weiter
zurückgeht zur zeit sterben in
deutschland etwa 1000 menschen pro woche
an coop 19 und bei dem anhalter
anhaltend hohen infektionszahlen ist
auch zu befürchten dass diese zahlen
nicht weiter sinken oder sogar noch
wieder ansteigen
diese wochen sind für uns alle schwer
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir als
gesellschaft zusammenstehen damit wir
diese dritte welle so gut wie möglich
bewältigen
wir haben im letzten jahr und auch in
den letzten wochen gesehen dass sich
sehr viele vor allem auch jüngere
menschen stark eingeschränkt haben um
infektionen zu vermeiden
sie haben dadurch ältere menschen die
besonders gefährdet sind und
risikopatienten vor coop 19 geschützt
und auch die kliniken vor einer noch
größeren belastung
inzwischen sind viele ältere
und risikopatienten glücklicherweise
geimpft aber die meisten menschen vor
allem die unter 60-jährigen und jüngeren
sind es noch nicht für kinder und
jugendliche steht bisher überhaupt noch
kein impfstoff zur verfügung
und dies sind genau die altersgruppen in
denen die infektionszahlen zurzeit immer
noch sehr hoch sind diese jüngeren noch
ungeschützten mitbürger sind weiter auf
die solidarität der gesellschaft
angewiesen die sie selbst zum schutz der
risikogruppen solange gezeigt haben
wir müssen uns bitte noch weiter
einschränken damit auch diese personen
eine chance haben sich impfen zu lassen
bevor das virus erwischt denn auch für
die jüngeren und gesunden ist dieses
virus nicht harmlos auch wenn das risiko
für einen tödlichen verlauf bei den
jüngeren jahrgängen deutlich geringer
ist
schwere verläufe können auch bei jungen
menschen auftreten und wir wissen noch
nicht genau wie viele personen an den
langzeitfolgen dem long kurve syndrom
leiden werden
die aktuelle studienlage deutet darauf
hin dass es 10 prozent sein könnten
müdigkeit schmerzen atembeschwerden und
neurologische beschwerden wie
konzentrations und denkstörungen zählen
zu den symptomen und wir wissen vor
allem auch noch nicht wie lange diese
folgeerkrankung anhält und wie sie sich
langfristig auf das leben auf das leben
der betroffenen auswirkt die impfung
gehen jetzt zügig voran eine weitere
beschleunigung ist zu erwarten
es ist absehbar dass bald jeder geimpft
werden kann
geben wir einen die zeit für geben wir
einen die zeit geben wir einen die
chance auf diese impfung
lassen sie uns weiter solidarisch sein
geimpfte und ungeimpfte um todesfälle
schwere verläufe und gesundheitlichen
langzeitfolgen zu verhindern sagte sie
und zum abschluss herzig
schönen guten morgen meine damen und
herren ich beginne mit einer guten
nachricht wenn dich sehr gute nachricht
wir haben ja vier zugelassene sichere
und hochwirksam und cupid 19 impfstoffe
verfügbar
sie wissen zwar im stoff zwei weg zur am
stoffe über seine new kid on the block
den ganzen stoff richtig in einem moment
halten sie sich vor augen dass wir noch
nie so früh zu neuen stoffen weltweite
erfahrung von millionenfachen in form
über die sicherheit und wirksamkeit
hatten und ich freue mich dass wir hier
auf volle transparenz bieten können in
beiderlei hinsicht selbst sehr sehr
nebenwirkungen die innerhalb von drei
monaten auftrat und sind inzwischen
bekannt und wir können einschätzen wie
gut diese impfstoffe sind die
wirksamkeit gegen chur wird vor allem
schwere verläufe ist sehr gut 80 bis 90
prozent im feld bereitet sich das große
phase 3 prüfung an mehreren zehntausend
impfung geimpften und effektivität
studien haben hier die entsprechenden
daten geliefert und es gibt auch erste
hinweise dass tatsächlich die weitere
ausbreitung von diensten des virus
zumindest reduziert werden kann
sprechen wir über den neuen ins tor von
jansen er sicher und wirksam
insbesondere auch bei älteren personen
über 60 jahre die wirksamkeit in
klinischen prüfung war dann über 22.000
geimpften mit diesem impfstoff geimpften
geprüft es gibt mehr monate nach
bearbeitung bis zu 82 prozent
wirksamkeit gegen jegliches kowitz
symptomatisch 85 prozent vor schwerem
verlauf bzw einen auf einlieferung
leichte bis mittelschwere reaktion
möglichen infektionen klingen nach drei
tagen ab sind bei älteren personen eher
schwächer und sie wissen dass es eine
diskussion darüber gibt das schwere
nebenwirkungen dieser ungewöhnlichen
thrombosen mit thrombozytopenie
aufgetreten sind aber bitte noch mal
wahrzunehmen dass wir in den usa hier
lediglich acht meldungen haben nach st
millionen impfungen das heißt die
meldung häufigkeit berichtet war eins zu
einer million
und ich verweise da auf die hinweise für
ärztinnen und ärzte aber auch für
geimpfte auf der webpage des
paul-ehrlich-instituts www.zeit.de um
schlimmeres zu verhindern
ich muss so einen moment noch mal zu
astrazeneca wachse wieder berichten hier
hat sich gezeigt dass in impfkampagnen
im vereinigten königreich die
wirksamkeit noch mal geprüft wurde im
alltagsgebrauch und sehr hoch liegt und
dass die thrombosen mit thrombozytopenie
weiterhin nur sehr selten sind und
vorwiegend bei personen unter 60 jahren
wir haben inzwischen den aus dem
vereinigten königreich aus schottland
und klinischen effektivitäts prüfung
wirksamkeit von 94 prozent
als schutz vor der krankenhauseinweisung
gegen chur wird der track hat sich mit
den sehr seltenen ungewöhnlichen
thrombosen befasst es gilt nun als neues
syndrom ist der kante nebenwirkung aber
ich kann berichten dass wir am
paul-ehrlich-institut weiterhin gemälde
häufigkeit von etwa 1 200 tausend haben
also sehr geringer häufigkeit und auf
die informationen auf unserer webpage
habe ich bereits hingewiesen
lassen sie mich für moment noch einen
weiteren ausblick geben was haben wir zu
erwarten weitere zulassung sind noch in
diesem halbjahr zu erwarten koubek der
impfstoff hier werden die phase 3
wirksamkeitsdaten der erste redoubt wie
man so schön sagt aus den großen
klinischen prüfung erwartet
nowaks ein protein im stoff der sich wie
sich gezeigt hat zu 90 prozent auch
gegen die südafrika variante wirkt und
dann sputnik wie der kombinierte
adenovirus sektor impfstoffe auch hier
hohe publizierte wirksamkeitsdaten gegen
kuwait vorliegen
die geschwindigkeiten möchte ich noch
mal sagen der zulassung hängt nicht von
uns ab wir sind da sehr schnell wie sich
in
monaten gezeigt hat sondern von der
datenlieferung der antragsteller die
zulassungs bewertungen im europäischen
bereich mit dem paul ehrlich institut
ist weiterhin sehr schnell und
sorgfältig wir haben volle transparenz
wenn sie sich orientieren würden so
haben wir routinemäßig periodisch die
zulassungs die verdachtsmeldung zu den
nebenwirkungen die impfkomplikationen
auf unserer webpage in den sicherheits
berichten www.gfei.de sicherheit der kuh
wie dämmstoffe die wirksamkeit gegen
varianten stellt sich ja sehr gut gegen
herkömmliche und britische variante da
etwas reduziert gegen würde
südafrikanischen variante brasilianische
variante und in die skiferien zu sind
auch nicht so klar
aber die wirksamkeit wird nicht nur sein
vermutlich reduziert ein weiterer punkt
sind die auftretenden varianten
selbstverständlich wir sind mit einer
reihe von herstellern und entwicklern im
gespräch darüber wie jetzt variante
impfstoff entwickelt werden können die
entsprechenden entwicklungen laufen
schon
wir haben dazu auf der europäischen
ebene einen leitfaden entwickelt der
eine vereinfachte prüfung erlaubt und
ebenfalls wurde der rechtliche rahmen
angepasst auf europäischer ebene so dass
auch hier einfache verfahren dazu führen
dass vier varianten stoffe haben werden
ich möchte in dem sinne zusammenfassen
wir freuen uns auf ihr hochwirksame
zugelassene impfstoffe auch der kunde
ist sehr sicher über 80 prozent wirksam
die meldedaten zu den ungewöhnlichen
thrombosen bei astrazeneca sind
weiterhin sehr gering noch geringer beim
jansen lebensstoff die ständige
impfkommission hat sich gestern zum
ersten mal damit befasst hat keine
einschränkung veranlasst in bezug auf
die empfehlung und vielleicht ganz zum
schluss eine kleine idee darüber wie wir
kämpfen um hier viele impfstoffe
verfügbar zu machen
wir haben beim bau und bei immer 124
wissenschaftliche beratung bisher
durchgeführt 40 klinische prüfung
genehmigt nur kurve bezogen 90
staatliche chargen freigaben gemacht
dafür davon 64 tatsächlich experimentell
geprüft
und selbstverständlich bei immer wieder
umgeben gespräch dankeschön
danke dafür dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen ich habe schon einige fragen
online unter anderem zu impfungen es
gibt auch nachfragen zur notbremse
vielleicht kriegen wir es halbwegs
geordnet wir werden sehen
noch mal ein hinweis ich bitte sie eine
frage zu stellen gegebenenfalls eine
nachfrage wenn sie eine zweite haben
seien sie so fair sich wieder hinten auf
die liste setzen zu lassen dass
möglichst viele kollegen ihre fragen
stellen können und wir beginnen im saal
bei herrn schmidt wenn sie das mikro vor
sich nehmen wäre das prima und können
sie können sie ein bisschen näher ans
mikro gehen sonst verstehen sie die
kollegen im stream nicht anhören stade
vor allen dingen aber vielleicht auch
anderen sparen
das erklärt vor ostern von einer
instrument von 300 höher geplant davon
gesprochen jetzt beobachten wir sagen
das war eine seitwärtsbewegung obwohl
die mutante sich jetzt für die britische
komplett durchgesetzt hat jetzt gibt es
mehr im tempo ist die ausgangssperre
beschlossen es wird wahrscheinlich bald
wärmer und sonniger deswegen beurteilen
sie die chance dass die dritte welle
tatsächlich gerade bericht und wie
beurteilen sie so oder was erwarten sie
denn zu nährwerten kommenden vier wochen
ja also zunächst wir machen ja modelle
wir machen projektionen ausgehend von
der situation wie sie zu dem zeitpunkt
ist und die situation war ebenso dass
wir ein exponentielles wachstum auch
über eine längere zeit erwarten konnten
wir haben jetzt positive effekte gesehen
auf die auf den einfluss der fallzahlen
man kann die allen erstmal nicht
abbilden in solchen modellen das ist
punkt 1 und zum anderen ist es ja auch
so dass eben durch letztendlich die
warnung die wir damit aussprechen auch
sich verhalten verändert also insofern
sehen wir schon auch in der
kommunikation die ja nicht nur wir dazu
machen sondern auch andere
wissenschaftler und auch politiker und
andere gesellschaftliche gruppen dann
schon auch 1 1 eine maßnahme an sich
damit eben verhalten und mobilität sich
ändert und das konnten wir eben über
ostern gut sehen den einfluss den wir
dort der zehn gehen wir also den wir
jetzt sehen auf die aktuellen
entwicklungen führen wir schon zu einem
gutteil auf die entwicklung um ostern
zurück
die mobilität steigt aber wieder so dass
durchaus die gefahr besteht dass diese
zahlen weiter ansteigen
und ich denke wir brauchen auf jeden
fall dort weitere auch flankierende
maßnahmen im bereich der letztendlich
neunten pharmaceutical interventions
rüber dass neben reduktion von kontakten
die dann auch letztendlich eben über die
politik in umgesetzt werden um diese
effekte zu erzielen also insofern halte
ich das für richtig wir sehen ein effekt
dieser maßnahmen insgesamt das ist gut
so das macht uns an der stelle auch froh
dass unsere prognose hier so nicht
eingetroffen ist und wir müssen
letztendlich weiter vorsichtig sein um
jetzt diese entwicklung nicht weiter
wieder zu beschleunigen oder die
infektion und kontakte davon hängt
letztendlich entscheidend ab wie die
entwicklung in den nächsten monaten ist
und in den nächsten wochen
insofern kann ich ihnen eine exakte
prognose nicht machen die modelle werden
angepasst auch an die aktuelle
entwicklung an das aktuelle kontakt
muster wir werden das auch zur gegebenen
zeit
wieder veröffentlichen und eine neue
angepasste prognose machen
die hat unsicherheiten wie alle
prognosen und modelle die man
letztendlich aufstellt aber darüber
hinaus kann ich ihnen jetzt nicht exakt
sagen wie es weitergeht hängt vor allem
davon ab auch wie letztendlich die
maßnahmen in der zukunft eingehalten
werden die nächste frage hat hier rinke
zum impfen
ersparen sie haben ja die zahl der
geimpften genannt die stark steigt wie
haben am montag an bund länder treffen
können sie sagen ob ihrer meinung nach
jetzt der zeitpunkt gekommen ist dass
man recht von gm wieder zurückgibt
lockerung zur hälfte gibt also zuerst
einmal ist gut dass am montag wir noch
mal miteinander schauen bund und länder
das ja auch ein gemeinschaftswerk ist
von anbeginn an wo wir stehen beim
impfen zum einen ich habe die
entwicklung ja gerade dargestellt weil
wir auch eine deutlich andere lage haben
als im ersten quartal
es war wie angekündigt im dezember im
ersten quartal knapp jetzt im zweiten
ist es anders und gemeinsames
verständnis zu haben über das was ich
auch gerade gesagt habe im mai trio 3 im
laufe des junis dann die weitere öffnung
das finde ich wichtig zum zweiten
übrigens ab juni nach unseren planungen
auch die betriebsärzte dann als teil der
impfkampagne
zum einen wegen der impfmenge aber wenn
ich dazu sagen dafür kommen ja dann auch
in eine andere phase die man sich jetzt
vielleicht noch gar nicht vorstellen
kann noch impfen wir diejenigen die
unbedingt geimpft werden wollen das auch
gut so
aber es kommt ja dann sozusagen die
phase wo es um diejenigen geht die sich
vielleicht noch unsicher sind die noch
überlegen die vielleicht wollen den aber
der aufwand mit einem termin vereinbaren
so hoch ist die fragen haben und da ist
betriebliches impfen im alltag in der
lebenswelt wie stelle ich erreichbar wie
bei anderen fraktionen auch natürlich
auch ein sehr sehr wichtiges instrument
und auch aus dem grund wollen wir im
juni die betriebe regelhaft mit
einbeziehen das ist der eine teil der
andere teil ist er den sie an
wochen haben wie ist es mit geimpften
und denjenigen die dann eine
abgeschlossene immunisierung haben jeder
wird ja wenn er nicht im ried ist
irgendwie zu einer immunisierung kommen
entweder wird die infektion durch machen
oder sie oder sich impfen lassen und
idealerweise aus meiner sicht jedenfalls
ist der bevorzugte weg die impfung und
da gibt es zwei oder drei
fallkonstellationen zu unterscheiden die
erste ist die und die haben wir ja im
auftrag auch der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz durch einen
bericht des robert-koch-instituts
sozusagen definiert ist die frage wie
behandle ich vollständig geimpfte in
relation zu tagesaktuell negativ
getesteten da sind wir ja im grunde auch
schon im ergebnis und in der umsetzung
dass das eine gleichbehandlung möglich
ist das robert koch institut hat die
quarantäne empfehlungen für enge
kontaktpersonen entsprechend angepasst
dass keine quarantäne erfordernis da es
wir passen an sind in der anpassung in
dem ressort abstimmung und gesprächen zu
den einreise verordnungen zum beispiel
dass bei den tests pflichten die zur
einreise vorgesehen sind eine
vollständiger impfschutz gleichgestellt
wird und bei den öffnungszeiten oder den
konzepten die es gibt und geben soll
dann auch vor allem nach der dritten
welle nach dem brechen der dritten welle
die testen dann ja vorsehen beim
einzelhandel oder beim fußballspiel wo
auch immer das dann eben eine
vollständige impfschutz leicht ich also
dass gleichstellen von tagesaktuellen
negativer testung und vollständig
geimpft sein bei der frage wie ist das
infektionsrisiko
das ist nicht bei null ist ganz wichtig
deswegen gelten die anderen regeln
weiter abstand für jene alltag mit maske
aber es ist deutlich reduziert
die andere frage ist und die ist
natürlich nach dem vierten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz und überhaupt
den maßnahmen der letzten monate dann
auch verfassungsrechtlich eine eine
weitere schwierige abwägung ist darf man
kann man jemanden der vollständig
geimpft ist noch beschränkungen wie
kontakt beschränkungen und ausgangs
beschränkungen auferlegen oder nicht
weil die sich natürlich herleiten aus
einem infektionsrisiko und
erkrankungsrisiko und dem schutz der
daraus
kommen soll und da gibt es natürlich die
interessen des einzelnen die sehr stark
in unserer freiheitlichen grundordnung
unbedingt die grundrechte sind
individualrechte zu werden sind und
gleichzeitig die schutzbedürfnisse
insgesamt für uns in dieser phase der
pandemie und dort sind wir mit dem
justizministerium dem innenministerium
mit den bundesressorts im engen
austausch um zur
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vor allem
auch erstmal noch meine herleitung und
der übersicht zu machen über diese
rechtsfragen und sie dort mit den
ländern zu erörtern und dann ist die
dritte frage habe ich als geimpfte ein
anspruch darauf dass die restaurants für
mich öffnen da sind soweit ich das war
nämlich die juristen sich ziemlich einig
dass es diesen anspruch nicht gibt also
etwas anderes ob ich eine beschränkung
erfahre wie eine ausgangs beschränkung
oder ob ein restaurant für mich noch
nicht wieder geöffnet ist wenn es denn
dann geöffnet wird mit dem test
erfordernis dann wäre ich ja wieder als
geimpfter also wenn ich geimpft wäre ich
bin noch nicht geimpft
es war jetzt beispiel das wäre man als
geimpfter dann entsprechend
gleichgestellt und diese dreieck hat
oder zwei kategorien finde ich wichtig
zu entscheiden
zu unterscheiden so und mit beiden
werden wir uns am montag befassen bei
meinen wirklich in der umsetzung negativ
getestet gleichgestellt mit kämpft und
bei dem anderen er in einer
grundsätzlichen debatte die dann in der
folge dann auch zu einer umsetzung
führen kann und soll durch die
verordnungsermächtigung die jetzt im
dritten bevölkerungsschutz gesetz ist
ist uns eine verordnung die so selten
gegeben hat denn der
bundesrepublikanischen geschichte
nämlich eine bundes regierungsverordnung
mit gleichzeitigem zustimmen von
bundestag und bundesrat
das habe ich bis jetzt erst einmal
übrigens erlebt so ähnlich bei einer
pflegeberufe verordnung
ansonsten geht es dass ein sehr
untypische konstruktion macht aber sinn
da ist eine hohe akzeptanz braucht trat
bei dieser frage klar zu stellen also
unter wird kein beschluss fallen dass
geimpfte von der ausgangssperre
ausgenommen werden ich kann nicht
vorgreifen was am montag entschieden
wird ich bin gast auf einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wie der
name schon sagt es wird diskutiert
werden ob wir schon so weit wären dass
es dazu entscheidungen kommt es kann ich
ihn am montag sagen niemand der stelle
mal eine frage dazu von gisela boy
gesundheitspolitischer
informationsdienst an die beiden
wissenschafter auf der bank zum zu den
wirkungen der impfung ein bisschen haben
sich schon was gesagt aber sie fragt bei
wie viel prozent liegt etwa der absolute
impfschutz der impfungen und was ist
also zum zum unterschied zu und
relativen und absoluten schutz und ihn
hoch sehen sie in etwa den impfschutz
von genießen
vielen dank
absoluten schutz kann man nicht reden
in dem sinne dass wir schon vorher
wussten auch aus den entsprechenden
tierversuchen dass wir gegen
entsprechende respiratorische wären
jetzt keine vollständige ab wenn die im
sinne bekommen das auch geimpfte nicht
kurzzeitig wenigstens eine reduzierte
infektion erleiden die ihm schütze die
gemessen werden die ich zitiert habe bei
über 80 190 prozent beziehen sich auf
kur wird das heißt jedwede symptomatik
nach dieser kurzzeitigen infektion oder
sogar darauf dass schwere verläufe
vermieden werden krank aus einweisung
wegen kubik oder todesfälle
da sind die raten sehr hoch die betragen
80 90 prozent ich habe sortiert beim
ganzen impfstoff ist sogar in der
wirksamkeit prüfung der phase 3 gefunden
worden dass dieser prozentsatz auch bei
älteren genauso hoch ist ist ja defizit
in manchen früheren klinischen prüfung
gegeben
danke dann machen wir weiter im seiner
frau berheide vielen dank
wie der stand bei den kinder impfstoff
oder für jugendliche momentan aussieht
und dann vielleicht dazu noch die
politische einordnung von minister
sparen was sie denn jetzt eltern sagen
wird und welcher mit kindern sagen wie
eben wieder von den ganzen möglichen
lockerungen im sommer eben noch nicht
profitieren können weil eben deren
kinder beispielsweise noch nicht steht
werden können kann ich gerne im detail
beurteilen und nochmal darstellen
sie wissen dass der biontech weiser den
stoff schon ab 16 zugelassen ist
ansonsten hat dieses firmen kontraktion
im märz 20 21 mit einer studium bei
kindern von sechs monaten
wir haben begonnen die studienergebnisse
werden der 20 21 erste vielleicht schon
früher und bei positiven ergebnissen
anfang 22 einreichung auf der
europäischen ebene und auch der us ebene
erwartet moderner dezember 2020 eine
studio mit jugendlichen ab zwölf jahren
bis unter 18 jahren gestartet und diese
studien bewegen sich im rahmen von
mehreren hundert bis mehreren tausend
kindern die einbezogen werden inzwischen
gibt es auch einen studien usa und
kanada bei kindern im alter von sechs
monaten unter zwölf jahren universität
oxford und astrazeneca seit februar 20
21 studie mit minderjährigen in uk das
waren 300 jugendliche teilnehmen
jansen hat anfang 20 21 begonnen das
heißt die gibt's jede menge aktivitäten
mit diesen entsprechenden impfstoffen um
mir relativ schnell zu ergebnissen zu
kommen und dann auch zu einer zu lassen
zu der frage wie ja auch mit der frage
von geimpften und der möglichkeit
bestimmte dinge zu tun oder nicht tun zu
müssen
zusammenhängt zum ersten was den
gesundheitsschutz angeht der kinder und
jugendlichen ist es jetzt dann eben im
ersten schritt sehr wichtig zu zum
schutz der kinder und jugendlichen hier
umfeld vollständig zu impfen
solange wir sie nicht selbst impfen
können deswegen kann ich auch nur dafür
werben wer selbst mit kindern und
jugendlichen regelmäßig zu tun hat das
impfangebot daran zu nehmen weil man
tatsächlich nicht nur sich selbst
schützt sondern eben diejenigen die sich
noch nicht schützen können weil noch
kein impfstoff verfügbar
das zweite ist die frage der
beschränkung wenn es ausnahmen gäbe für
vollständig geimpft dann kann man wird
man ja nicht sagen können aber für
kinder bleiben die auf jeden fall alle
gültig weil können im moment noch nicht
geimpft werden das ist aber eine der
schwierigen fragen zu diskutieren sind
auch in den nächsten tagen und all diese
themen das sehen wir ja schon an der
debatte haben sich das risiko oder
zumindest das potenzial auch zu einer
gesellschaftlichen spaltung zu führen
ich finde sehr wichtig dass wir diese
debatte führen sie muss geführt werden
verstehen individuelle freiheitsrechte
gegen die frage des des bevölkerungs und
gesundheitsschutzes in der pandemie und
die frage wie man es auch möglichst fair
macht ganz fair dass jedes fair und
gerecht findet ist schon in der familie
meistens nicht möglich
in einer gesellschaft auch selten und
bei einer so fundamentalen frage noch
viel schwerer
und da hängt natürlich gerade die fragen
was ist mit denen die noch gar nicht
geimpft werden können auch sehr mit mit
dran
aus meiner sicht muss man da eine lösung
finden weil es ja weder lebenspraktisch
noch ethisch irgendwie vernünftig wäre
zu sagen
alle können sich irgendwie impfen lassen
und haben keine beschränkungen mehr aber
die zehnjährigen schon noch das sehe ich
nicht
und dafür brauchen wir gute kluge lösung
also rechts eine frage dazu online
gestellt von patrick hollstein apotheke
adhoc an herrn sichert wie bewerten sie
die freigabe von astrazeneca zur
anwendungen auf eigenes risiko bewerte
das als er von dem tiger maßnahme
sollten die lage in die lage versetzt
werden diesen impfstoff zu bekommen wir
klären auf über die risiken die damit
verbunden sind das ist eine persönliche
beurteilung und damit auch empfohlen
worden sich beim arzt darüber auch so
ein tieren zu lassen
insofern von vielen maßnahmen zum ganzen
impfstoff wird man abwarten ich hatte ja
hier berichtet dass wir bisher nur
erfahrungen aus den usa haben aber die
zeigen momentan dass die melde rate in
bezug auf diese sehr seltene
nebenwirkung nochmal unter ist das heißt
wir haben einen sprung von 100.000 rate
bei astra in deutschland und eins zu
einer million etwa in den usa und ist
eine klare kommunikation auf der
europäischen ebene von der immer
geschäftsstelle nach den sitzungen der
entsprechenden ausschuss erfolgt dass
der nutzen weit gegen mit den risiken
wenn ich kurz ergänzt essen mal her sich
rotex spricht immer von jansen also dass
johnson johnson jansen real die ansage
ist sozusagen der zulassungsinhaber in
europa im allgemeinen sprachgebrauch
sagen wir mal johnson johnson nur für
diejenigen die vielleicht überlegen was
meint es ist johnson johnson schlecht
durch jansen so zu sagen was ich aber
sagen wollte das astra zenica einfach
nur noch mal zur einordnung mit den
impfzahlen heute morgen sind im moment
wenige hunderttausend dosen astra zenica
unfair impft
also wir warten auf weitere lieferungen
wir haben jetzt bis ende juni liefert
daten und ankündigungen von biontech und
moderner von johnson johnson johnson
auch noch nicht so weit in die zukunft
und von astra zenica im moment überhaupt
nur eine noch nicht genau spezifiziert
der ankündigung die nächste woche
deswegen finde ich sehr wichtig in der
debatte einzuordnen es geht gerade um
einige hunderttausend impfdosen astra
zenica die noch nicht verimpft sind ich
hoffe es werden bald mehr wir erwarten
weitere lieferung aber im moment ist
dass die größenordnung die frage bezieht
sich darauf die fragen sie was sagen
hermine ist dazu der zum ausmaß der
ablehnung
die astrazeneca fährt also man liest er
als larven offensichtlich also leute
lassen impftermine verfallen und in dem
zusammenhang haben sie denn überlegt die
wahlfreiheit
menschen die 60 einfach einzuschränken
damit die mehr abbekommen und anstatt es
umgekehrt zu machen
also zuerst einmal sehen wer bei
astrazeneca jahr ist zeigen wir alle
umfragen und im zweifel auch die die
persönliche imperien ich das immer im
eigenen bekanntenkreis dass es da
natürlich mehr fragen und manchmal
zurückhaltend gibt aus unserer sicht
insbesondere über 60-jährigen
ungerechtfertigt professor eckhard
darauf hingewiesen zumal in einigen
parametern der astra zenica impfstoff
sogar wirksamer ist als der biontech
impfstoff gerade bei den älteren
aber wir haben ja auch gesehen ich habe
ja selbst in nordrhein-westfalen
wahrnehmen können als über 60 jährige
das angebot bekamen waren die dosen
räder also die impftermine relativ
schnell ausgebucht es gibt eine
hinreichend große zahl viele millionen
deutsche da bin ich sehr sicher
die eine schnelle impfung mit astra
zenica auch sofort annehmen würden
würden und werden und insofern sehe ich
da das problem nichts das es nicht fremd
kriegen die frage ist sozusagen wir sind
die zugänge und da haben wir jetzt ja in
dieser woche astra zenica auch erstmal
nicht in den arztpraxen in der impfung
auch da sind die zahlen so dass fünf
wird offenkundig und dadurch das jetzt
klar ist das war eine formulierung der
stand vorher nach ärztlichem ermessen in
der stiko empfehlung das wurde jetzt
sprachlich überarbeitet nach ärztliche
aufklärung weil das ermessen war so eine
weile unsicher was ist damit gemeint ist
klar ist wenn die aufklärung
dokumentiert ist und der impflinge für
sich entscheidet das zu machen dann geht
das auch und mein eindruck ist das
kriegen wir auch gut verkauft aber ja
nach den letzten wochen ist der zuspruch
zu als weniger etwas geringer als der
des vorbei und das sehen wird das ist so
ich kann aber nur dafür werben in dieser
phase der pandemie sollten wir sichere
und wirksame impfstoffe unter kenntnis
aller wirkungen und dem wir kommen
nutzen und die überlegung die
wahlfreiheit für 60
wir haben gar nicht genug astra hat
gerade gesagt wer moment nur wenige
hunderttausend dosen astra zenica
sozusagen die noch nicht verimpft sind
wir impfen aber gerade hoffentlich das
ist ja auch so notwendigerweise jeden
tag viele zigtausende über 60-jährige
weil wir wollen ja jetzt vor allem die
über 60 jährigen mit zuerst schützen das
risiko für einen schwersten schweren
verlauf ist bei über 60-jährigen etwa 60
mal so hoch wie bei unter 60 jährigen
wir haben in etwa jetzt die hälfte der
über 60 jährigen in deutschland
mindestens einmal geimpft und wir können
jetzt nicht warten bis astra zenica
sozusagen immer nach liefert sondern
müssen alle impfstoffe nutzen um vor
allem auch die über 60-jährigen zu
impfen
aber ja astra zenica wenn er da ist
sollte natürlich auch bevorzugt dann
auch dort zum einsatz kommen ihnen
nochmal zum thema impfungen gleich zwei
fragen in einem dazu agentur dass ein
kollege fragt er schreibt sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann habe in
moskau mitgeteilt dass deutschland 30
millionen dosen sputnik v erwerben will
bestätigen sie das und dann gibt es eine
frage von kollegen christian geinitz von
der faz zu moderner werk in deutschland
warum geht es dann nicht voran wo sie
doch die herstellung in der eu wünschen
ist es dass die eu jetzt gegen astra
weniger klagt ist auch noch eine frage
gleich drei auf einmal zum ersten gibt
es ja mit astra zenica tatsächlich
einfach debatten rund um den
liefertermin und die frage der
verhältnisse der verträge mit auch
anderen staaten und dem europäischen
vertrag vertragspartner ist die
europäische union die kommission und
wenn die sich entscheidet in den
klageweg zu gehen dann dann ja wir
stützen jetzt alle staaten ich bin immer
sehr dafür in einer pandemie wenn man
dann rechtliche auseinandersetzung
pflegen muss ist eigentlich schon kein
guter zustand von beiden
fragen her wir müssen das die frage
klären was an dem vertrag
problematisch ist in der umsetzung das
ist so das muss man auch sehr hart
miteinander austragen meinetwegen auch
juristisch aber mir ist viel wichtiger
dass ich diesen impfstoff kriege ich
meine davon dass wir gerichtsverfahren
führen habe ich nicht eine dose mehr
sondern dass wir kooperativ mit astra
zenica zu möglichst vielen lieferungen
möglichst schnell kommen und
gleichzeitig man natürlich auch
rechtsfragen und schadens und
haftungsfragen geklärt aber die stimmt
für mich im moment in dieser phase der
pandemie noch nicht prioritär für mich
ist noch prioritär dass wir im diesen
kriegen kooperativ sport nicht v ich
sage jetzt nichts zu details von
vertragsverhandlungen sie wissen das
habe ich ja auch vor zwei drei wochen
gesagt dass nachdem die europäische
union sich entschieden hat nicht mit dem
russischen hersteller in verkehr bringen
zu verhandeln
dass die bundesrepublik deutschland sich
entschieden hat vertrags- verhandlungen
aufzunehmen mit einem zwei ganz
wichtigen prämissen die erste ist die
europäische zulassung und herr professor
siegfried eckert gerade darauf
hingewiesen dass paul ehrlich institut
ist auch reporter wie das heißt also
berichterstatter haupt bewährter im
rahmen des europäischen
zulassungsprozess für diesen impfstoff
und es liegt nicht am
paul-ehrlich-institut und den behörden
sondern an der frage welche daten und
datenpakete werden wie umfangreich und
zuverlässig geliefert
das hat auch schon erste inspektion in
der werkstatt gefunden auch da gibt es
dann noch im bedarf zu schauen wenn dann
braucht es eine europäische zulassung
über den anderen impfstoffen auch und
dafür trotz die daten
das zweite ist es muss dann natürlich
nur ein unterschied machen für diese
impfkampagne also im januar oder im
november oder wahrscheinlich auch schon
im september macht jetzt keinen großen
unterschied mehr für uns angesichts der
impfstoffe die wir erwarten dürfen
und all diese facetten werden verhandelt
von der taskforce impfstoffe wo er bmw
bmf bmw zusammen agieren mit der
russischen seite aber zu vertrags und
verhandlungsdetails entstanden
nicht stellung die dritte das dritte war
sorry ganz viel auf einmal moderner werk
das muss ich jetzt tatsächlich da kenne
ich den ganz aktuellen stand nicht weil
wir haben ja das thema der investitionen
in produktionskapazitäten gemeinsam in
die task force wir haben jetzt so viele
taskforce dass man immer noch mal ändern
muss welche macht was die taskforce
impfstoffproduktion gegeben also die die
ich gerade erwähnt hat
wirtschaftsministerium
gesundheitsministerium finanzministerium
weil es ja um investitionszuschüsse geht
und das sind natürlich klassische
vergaberechtliche investitions verfahren
die wir als gesundheitsministerium gar
nicht alleine in der größenordnung sonst
machen und deswegen ist es wichtig dass
zusammen zu machen
da gibt es gespräche mit moderner das
ist ja auch schon in den medien gewesen
den genauen stand kann ich jetzt aktuell
nicht geben das müssen wir nacharbeiten
dann mache mir im saal weiter bei ihnen
wo mir der name gerade entfallen ist
spiekermann zdf hauptstadtstudio
ich würde ganz gerne auf die kollateral
auf die sogenannten kollateralschäden zu
sprechen kommen sie müssten also könnten
wir erheblich sein
gibt es überlegungen im ministerium die
man mit anderen wählen als der dritten
welle umgeht also da gibt es ja offenbar
könnten sich neu wählen entwickeln und
was man stets erkrankung betrifft und
die zweite frage die ich habe ist wie
sie in den den aufruf gestern von den
künstlern und künstlerinnen bewerten
also der heute oder gestern der bild
zeitung erschien
wie bewerten sie die kritik die an der
groner politik zum ersten sie man jetzt
schäden den fragen von anderen
gesundheits auf erkrankungen entstehen
dadurch dass behandlungen verschoben
werden oder verschoben und das man halt
also dass leute auch nicht zur
vorsorgeuntersuchung gehen
das ist ja etwas was wo wer jetzt auch
schon viele experten warnen dass danach
bekämpfen sozialpakt ganz neue wellen
auf also das nehmen wir nämlich auch
persönlich sehr ernst
weil das tatsächlich etwas ist was wir
auch einfach sehen in den
abrechnungsdaten in den behandlungsdaten
es gibt bestimmte bereiche von
behandlungen und operationen wo
möglicherweise gar kein nachholbedarf
entsteht wir sehen übrigens auch dass
bestimmte erkrankung so moment gar nicht
also auf eine intensivstation copd also
die lungenerkrankung mit zusammen mit
dem viralen infekt hat häufig in der
vergangenheit zu einer
intensivbehandlung geführt da im moment
viel weniger virale infekte sind weil
alle sich schützen
sehen wir viel weniger copd patienten
auf den intensivstationen also es hat
positive effekte aber es hat in
bestimmten bereichen natürlich hat eine
verschobene krebs operation oder eine
nicht wahrgenommene vorsorgeuntersuchung
dann auch folgen kann folgen haben und
deswegen ist ja dass wichtige kriterium
da wo es auch medizinisch vertretbar ist
überhaupt nur was zu verschieben das ist
eine ärztliche entscheidung und bei den
vorsorgeuntersuchungen oder auch den den
sonstigen fragen wann gehe ich zum arzt
und mit einer beschwerde und stelle mich
vor werden wir sicherlich nach dieser
welle wenn das sich auch wieder hat
weiter normalisieren können im
gesundheitswesen auch sehr dafür werben
nicht gemachte vorsorgeuntersuchungen
übrigens auch nicht gemachte impfung bei
kindern
wir sehen auch dass viele der
vorsorgeuntersuchungen u es gibt nur 12
4 6
dass diese vorsorgeuntersuchung auch
deutlich weniger gemacht werden im
moment die auch wirklich nachzuholen das
ist sehr sehr wichtig weil sonst eben
vieles nicht erkannt wird wie gesagt das
nehmen wir sehr ernst und begleiten das
auch und schauen auch in die
abrechnungsdaten mit den kassen zusammen
was die frage angeht ich habe
ehrlicherweise noch nicht mir selbst
alles anschauen können
zuerst mal bestandteil einer einer
öffentlichen diskussion und dass es
kritik gibt an den massnahmen dass es
kritik und fragen gibt an
den maßnahmen und den hintergründen das
finde ich nur normal das finde ich in
der freiheitlichen demokratie auch ein
fischens wert am ende ich wäre eher
besorgt wenn es überhaupt keine kritik
gebe weil es am ende notwendig ist dass
das was wir tun dass wir das auch
rechtfertigen dass wir uns erklären dass
wir erläutern dass wir es herleiten dass
wir es ab wegen das ist ja der prozess
der dann auch im bundestag stattgefunden
hat in den debatten dokumentiert hat ist
ja nicht so dass das mal eben eins zu
eins und alle haben gesagt genau so und
nicht anders muss man es jetzt machen
das waren ja sehr kontroverse diskussion
gesellschaftlich politisch in ganz
vielen bereichen und das was ich
wahrgenommen habe bis jetzt muss man das
noch genauer anschauen ist ja auch eine
kritik daran dass es angeblich keine
kritik gebe und ich finde da müssen wir
also ich nehmen nicht wahr dass diese
debatten nicht kontrovers verlaufen
also ich habe wo ich bin habe ich eine
kontroverse diskussion ist auch gut so
zu diesen themen und ich nehme auch
nicht wahr dass es nicht kontrovers
meinungsäußerung etwa auch aus der
wissenschaft gelb jeden tag wenn ich
zeitung aufschlage wenn ich online
medien aufschlage wenn ich sendungen
schauer gibt es doch kontroverse
diskussion und ich fände es schade wenn
der eindruck da wäre dass es nicht auch
kontroverse abwägende diskussionen gibt
entscheidend ist dass wir im gespräch
miteinander bleiben
sie kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen ich
weiß nicht wer da jetzt die initiatoren
sind gespräch miteinander zu führen weil
ich einfach wahnsinnig wichtig finde
immer wieder aufs neue
dieses gespräch zu suchen in einer
schwierigen phase die mit ganz vielen
herten und es sind ja eher künstlerinnen
und künstler vor allem wie gerade eben
auch ich meine man ist ja schauspieler
geworden zum beispiel auch ja weil man
weil man es liebt wenn man es gerne
macht ist der berufung auch und das
jetzt über monate nicht ausüben zu
können dass das dass das auch weh tut
neben der finanziellen situation das
kann ich gut verstehen dass man das zum
ausdruck bringen will und gleichzeitig
ist die pandemie ja auch was wir uns
alle nicht ausgesucht haben
darüber muss man reden und darüber suche
ich auch gerne das gespräch
damit glaube ich ist die frage von anja
meyer von visa korea auch beantwortet
die nach dieser initiative fragte wenn
nicht bitte nochmal schreiben
ich würde jetzt noch mal online fragen
dazu nehmen als sehr viele gibt nochmal
zum thema notbremse detail nachfragen
ich starte mal wieder mit zwei
gleichzeitig basil wegener dpa fragt
haben sie einen überblick ob die länder
ihre von den berechnungen hofft
abweichenden inzidenz werte zur
grundlage für die notbremse nehmen oder
gelten generell die eckzahlen für alle
ist eine frage und christoph brandner
von der nzz fragt gibt es damit de facto
eine nacht reiseverbot in landkreisen
mit einer inzidenz über 100 starten wir
nun mit den beiden also es ist gesetz
sagt ja sehr klar dass die vom rkw
veröffentlichten werte zählen zum ersten
und zum zweiten heißt die ausgangs
beschränkung tatsächlich daneben außer
für die triftigen gründe die gesetzlich
genannt werden dann nicht raus zu gehen
heißt also auch nicht zu reisen dann
nehme ich gleich noch mal die anderen
beiden fragen dazu muss um die schulen
geht sascha meyer dpa fragt aus den
ländern kommen warnungen dass deswegen
des schwellenwertes 165 bei schulen ein
hin und her geben könnte wie kann das
vermieden werden um die akzeptanz nicht
zu gefährden ist eine frage und malte
kreutzfeldt von der taz fragt herrn
schade halten sie es für sinnvoll dass
für schulschließungen die allgemeine
incidents ist wäre es nicht sinnvoller
dafür die institute in der altersgruppe
der schüler zu nutzen
also kann ich gerne anfangen also die
inzidenz das wissen ja das ziel
unterschiedlich sind in den
altersklassen auch im verlauf einzelner
wellen bewegen sich die instanzen
praktisch durch die altersjahrgänge in
der regel fängt das er in den mittleren
jahrgängen an und entwickelt sich dann
zu den eltern und zu den jüngeren hin
bei dieser welle sehen wir auch schon
den beginn bei den jüngeren jahrgängen
also das spricht natürlich schon erstmal
dafür dass man das auch differenziert
betrachtet er ist natürlich schwierig
letztendlich war das eine so dynamische
entwicklung ist und wenn man auch immer
bedenken muss das ja infektionsketten
und infektions netzwerke auch über
einzelne sag ich mal gesellschaftliche
bereiche hinausgehen
sie sind vernetzt auch mit somit den
haushalten mit ihren eltern und auch
anderen verwandt mit ihren freunden das
jetzt so strikt in diese so zu strategie
zieren das man nur bestimmte
altersjahrgänge nimmt man muss immer ja
auch das gesamtgeschehen mit beachten
also das denke ich ist im moment auch
noch eine gute lösung wir werden
allerdings natürlich in die situation
kommen dass wenn die älteren jahrgänge
zunehmend geimpft werden und am ende
dann hauptsächlich noch die unter
20-jährigen übrig bleiben das dann sich
diese frage in der tat noch mal ganz neu
stellt weil dann hätten wir da ja ein
vielfaches der inzidenz von der die wir
jetzt 200 in der bevölkerung haben und
ob man dann den schülern und jungen
erwachsenen
dieses hohe infektionsgeschehen noch
zumuten kann das bleibt die frage
andererseits kann ich diese frage noch
nicht ganz beantworten weil wir ja nicht
wissen wie dann die virus zirkuliere bei
so einer hohen quote tatsächlich
aussehen wird also die überlegung finde
ich genau richtig und wir müssen das im
auge behalten ob durch diese regelung in
zukunft sich hier infektionsgeschehen in
dieser altersgruppe aufbauen die einfach
nicht mehr toleriert werden können ich
übrigens was sie mich in den letzten
zwei wochen diskussion häufig erreicht
hat nämlich sie zum beispiel eine frage
wenn 50 prozent schon geimpft werden und
man hätte dann noch hunderte incidents
ob die dann nicht anders zu beurteilen
wäre dann sag ich ja es wäre noch viel
schlimmer
also viele haben immer gesagt werde auch
dann eigentlich weniger schlimm aber es
ist eigentlich noch viel schlimmer weil
auf die hälfte der bevölkerung ist
eigentlich 200 der insolvenz dann
sozusagen umgerechnet wenn eigentlich
ein großteil dann gar nicht mehr
teilnehmen würde am infektionsgeschehen
weil schon geimpft
unabhängig davon zu der frage der
sozusagen tageweise wechselwirkungen es
muss ja immer mehrere tage in folge über
dem wert der landkreis liegen und dann
mindestens fünf tage in folge jeden tag
darunter also dass das jetzt täglich
schwankt ergibt sich daraus nicht
ich bleibe auch weiterhin dabei es ist
eine note
ich kann nicht an empfehlen immer zu
warten bis zur notbremse regelung bevor
man maßnahmen ergreifen gottseidank
machen sie ausdrücklich sagen die
allermeisten länder und kreisfreien
städte und landkreise ja auch so dass
sie vorher schon beginnen maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
die erfahrung ist allerdings wenn man
sozusagen auf dem weg durch eine solche
stelle ist dass das leider zu oft dann
nicht binnen weniger tage wieder wieder
drunter ist
und wenn es dann so wäre über fünf tage
nacheinander dann aber auch nach allen
erfahrungen für dann länger also das
risiko ist nicht bei null
aber es ist eigentlich durch diese tage
die es jeweils aufeinander folgend
dieser wert so rum und so rum erreicht
sein muss nicht so dass das täglich
schwanken kann und der entsprechende
entsprechende sicherheit einfach dass da
nicht statistik fragen oder ein
einzelner ausbruch in einem kita oder
was weiß ich in einer pflegeeinrichtung
ja nicht mehr so viel aber in einer
bestimmten institution das dann
entsprechend verändert dann eben dadurch
abgemildert
ich habe noch sechs fragen insgesamt auf
der liste wenn wir die kurz halten und
die antworten kurzen schaffen wir
vielleicht mit einem leichten über zug
der zeit dass die nächste kommt von den
kollegen hinter frau spiekermann das
mikro vor ihnen wäre prima hinter ihm
zwei von watson ich habe eine frage an
herrn spahn und fahren soll die em in
diesem sommer publikum stattfinden
da wollte ich dir gerne fragen ob sie
das für vertretbar halten auch
hinsichtlich im austragungsort münchen
das ist eine frage von der mit der ich
mich morgen sogar schon beschäftigt habe
aber noch nicht aufgelöst habe
das müssen wir einfach noch mal
miteinander in der bundesregierung und
mit münchen und bayern sprechen wenn wir
dahin kommen dass wir generell
veranstaltungen test gestützt mit
hygiene es geht nicht darum dass das
stadion wieder 60.000 verlässt sondern
mit reduzierter zahl abstand
hygienemaßnahmen test gestützt
dann finde ich kann man das aus heutiger
sicht nicht ausschließen lassen sollte
man auch nicht zu viele erwartungen
wecken und deswegen möchte ich einfach
dass wir das auch noch mal miteinander
abstimmen mit dem ministerium für sport
zuständig ist ja auch eine europäische
meisterschaft hat ja nun auch mehr
wir gucken da rüber hinaus und einfach
mit den mit mit bayern und münchen
aber wenn wir davon ausgehen wovon wir
ausgehen wollen dass es gelingt diese
dritte welle zu brechen und den test
gestützt öffnung schritte zu gehen würde
natürlich auch derartige veranstaltung
wie auch andere spiele und
sportveranstaltungen dann darunter
fallen können
es arbeiten oder so schwierig die wollen
das natürlich am liebsten alles drei
monate vorher wissen und das macht es so
schwierig die nächste frage hat frage an
professor schade ich würde ganz gerne
ihre einschätzung wird schon über das so
genannte indische oder die indische
virusvariante wie gefährlich halten die
sie auf cd und was wissen sie im
zusammenhang der wirkung auf verdienen
ja also die indische variante wird ja
auch als so genannte doppel variante
bezeichnet weil es zwei mutationen gibt
in diesem sogenannten protein das ist ja
das womit das virus an die zellen
andockt und es wird unterstellt dass die
eine mutation eben die hohe rate also
die antikörper antwort etwas unterdrückt
oder unterläuft und die andere
mutationen die zelluläre den zweiten arm
der immunantwort
das ist die theorie dahinter wenn man
das war ähnliche mutationen gesehen hat
und stellt sich jetzt vor dass es bei
dieser doppel mutante dann
ein sich gegenseitig verstärken den
effekt gibt das ist aber noch
keinesfalls irgendwie belegt in
letztendlich laborversuchen dafür gibt
es noch keine daten so dass es eine
theoretische überlegung ist und wir
sehen eben gleichzeitig in indien
einerseits ein sehr starkes
infektionsgeschehen praktisch über das
land hinweg sehr starke verbreitung
dieser indischen mutante in einigen
landesteilen wo auch rohes
infektionsgeschehen ist es aber offenbar
nicht gleichartig verteilt in allen
landesteilen und so ergibt sich dann die
schlussfolgerung dass an dieser hohen
infektionsgeschehen diese doppel mutante
eben ursächlich sein muss ich denke das
kann man so verkürzt nicht sagen es gibt
auch andere faktoren im moment in indien
die deutlich zur infektionsweg beitragen
also das eben kein lockdown dort besteht
dass eben bestimmte große
veranstaltungen auch mit vielen
millionen menschen stattfinden
es sind alles faktoren die natürlich die
infektionen auch begünstigen
man könnte sich vorstellen dass ihr
beide faktoren eine gewisse rolle
spielen aber jetzt zu sagen dass dieses
virus besonders stark sich verbreitet
ich denke das kann man noch nicht tun
und man kann auch nicht sagen dass es
eine moon escape variante ist weil wir
beide dinge eigentlich noch nicht die
belege fehlen noch die belege fehlen
beides sind möglichkeiten deswegen
können wir diese momente auch unter
beobachtung aber wir würden sie im
moment auch noch nicht als
besorgniserregende variante einstufen
sondern als variante unter beobachtung
[Musik]
also es ist im bereich der möglichkeiten
ist natürlich dass diese variante uns
vor neue herausforderungen stellt das
ist denkbar aber die belege dass das
tatsächlich so ist ich denke die sind im
moment einfach noch nicht das ist eine
möglichkeit wir müssen da hinschauen
warnungen müssen ernstgenommen werden
und ansonsten müssen wir uns das jetzt
noch mal weiter angucken und natürlich
versuchen zu vermeiden dass es zu
in weiteren importe nach deutschland
kommt dass diese variante ist ja in
deutschland auch bereits nachgewiesen
worden 21-mal bisher also
einzelnachweise wir sehen noch keine
tendenz zur großen verbreitung innerhalb
von deutschland aber wir haben das im
blick und wir haben das im blick
sozusagen fachlich wissenschaftlich aber
natürlich auch politisch sie wissen dass
wir das instrument der virus varianten
gebiete haben ist ein langes wort aber
es hat eben zur folge sehr starke
transport beförderungs einschränkungen
was flugverkehr angeht und einreise
einschränkungen wie wir sie auch bei
anderen ländern noch haben wir etwa
brasilien und natürlich wäre das bei
entsprechender erkenntnislage dann auch
für indien und möglicherweise andere
länder großbritannien das ja eine
historisch und auch einfach
lebensweltlich oder praktisch reise
mäßig sehr eng mit indien verwoben ist
er deutlich mehr fälle bisher schon
nachgewiesen
müssen wir uns anschauen schließen nicht
aus dass es dann auch zu entsprechenden
maßnahmen ist die nächste frage ist
entschuldigung hätte ich das mit man
entspannt oder wer zuständig ist laut
dem neuen wochenbericht der influenza
arbeitsgruppe gab es diesen winter so
gut wie gar keine influenza also keine
schippe
die zahl der grippetoten betrug bis zu
25.000 im jahr nach schätzungen grund
das ist die nicht gaap jene maßnahmen
müsste man dann auch in zukunft wegen
dieser gefahr dann die hygienemaßnahmen
auch so beibehalten wo ist da die grenze
für sie danke also erst immer ist es
eine gute nachricht dass es im grunde
keine grippewelle in diesem jahr gegeben
hat oder gibt sie wäre im zweifel
vielleicht noch in den ausläufen jetzt
das zeigt tatsächlich die maßnahmen
machen einen unterschied für viele
infektionskrankheiten sind es ja nicht
nur bei der grippe oder auch andere
infektionskrankheiten gleichwohl ist es
ja nicht so dass das q2 und die folgen
vergleichbar wären mit den folgen der
grippe
wir sehen deutlich schwerer
deswegen sind wir ja auch zu einer
unterschiedlichen einschätzung in der
mast bei den maßnahmen gekommen zwischen
einer grippewelle und einer saß q2 welle
und diese unterschiedliche einschätzung
die wir haben einmal mehr ja auch belegt
durch die erkenntnisse der letzten
monate und in situationen nicht nur auf
den intensivstationen auch was long
kurbelt angeht ist man auch schauen wir
schauen immer sehr stark auf nicht
nachvollziehbarer weise auf die zahl der
zu beklagenden todesfälle auf der
intensivstation wir haben auch viele
andere folgen dieser erkrankung und
deswegen kommen wir eben dann auch im
umgang mit einer möglichen welle zu
einer unterschiedlichen einschätzung
zumal es einen wichtigen unterschied
geht bei der grippewelle haben wir schon
seit vielen vielen jahren weiß er nicht
wahrscheinlich schon seit jahrzehnten
impfstoffe bei dieser eben bisher erst
seit vier monaten aber doch noch mal
ganz konkret die frage das ist ja eine
moralische frage eine sehr
schwerwiegende wo wo ziehen sie die
grenze nach welchen maßstäben bei 25.000
wenn man sie vermeiden kann mit
hygienemaßnahmen nach dem jetzigen
maßstäben müsste man das auch machen
also zuerst einmal 25.000 ist eine
schätzung für 2 18 19 wenn ich richtig
im kopf hat gewesen als wir eine sehr
sehr schwere grippe welle hatten das ist
nicht jährlich so es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche situation der letzten
jahre zum zweiten gibt es eine impfung
und zum dritten deutlich andere verläufe
wusst ich kann ihnen jetzt nicht
definieren ab wann sie sind ja viele
parameter es gibt ja nicht den einen
parameter der jetzt sagt ab dann ist es
eine eine eine pandemie eine epidemische
lage weil der mann dann automatisch zu
diesen maßnahmen greift das ist zu zu
digital 01 gedacht das ist aus meiner
sicht nicht möglich sondern es ist am
ende ja immer ein gesamtbild und wir
haben bei coop 19
diese erkrankung ja einfach erlebt
zugleich starker belastung und
überlastung ich meine nehmen sie die
situation in brasilien
wer immer mal schmerzhaft zähnen will
und das tut jedenfalls mir sehr weh das
zu sehen was passiert wenn man es
einfach laufen lässt
man sieht dass in einigen
der welt und das will ich vermeiden die
nächste frage
die kollegen hier vorn mit dem blauen
schal claudia plastal die
hauptstadtstudio minister sparen nochmal
zur im chor easy rung
sie haben es jetzt geziert und andere
nichts von lieferengpässen die wir auch
erlebt haben knappen
produktionskapazitäten was macht sie da
so sicher sie wirken fest überzeugt dass
im juni die priorisierung aufgehoben
werden kann könnten sie noch mal
skizzieren was sie da so sicher macht
sicher bis nichts aber zuversichtlich
100 prozent sicherheit gibt es natürlich
nicht was mich zuversichtlich macht ist
dass unser hauptlieferant piontek
oberbayern bio entec ich sage immer
gesagt ich würde es falsch aussprechen
aber jedenfalls sehr zuverlässig liefert
immer am gleichen zeitpunkt in der woche
immer die zugesagte menge das war anfang
des jahres kurzzeitig mal anders da gab
es ja auch ein paar situationen wie
schwierig war ganz am anfang
mittlerweile sehr zuverlässig und von 80
millionen dosen die wir im zweiten
quartal erwarten kommt 50 millionen von
diesem einen hersteller und wenn ich die
hochrechnungen und die lief auch schon
mit wochen menge angekündigt bis ende
juni
wenn jetzt nichts völlig und wenn das
werk in marburg abtrennte was gott
verhüten möge dann wäre die situation
natürlich eine andere
aber nach allem was wir mit menschlichem
ermessen annehmen können stand heute an
diesem freitag vormittag werden wir so
viele lieferungen bekommen in den
nächsten wochen auch vom biontech schon
bis ende juni angekündigt und astra
zenica und johnson johnson sagen
zuschauern zu die ganzen sagen dass sie
ihre quartals- zusage jedenfalls
einhalten werden dass wir dann diese
situation erreichen das macht mich
zuversichtlich aber nur 100 prozent
garantiert kann ich tatsächlich nicht
geben aber die können nicht nie geben
können wir im übrigen auch was
mutationen an genii abschließend geben
ich weiß doch wir waren doch alle auf
dem weg irgendwie innerlich raus aus der
zweiten welle
einen schönen frühling die zahlen gehen
runter ist wurde überall besser die
zahlen die alle parameter waren
auflockerungen weisen
und dann kamen die mutation ich weiß es
noch sehr genau vierten adventssonntag
fing es an mit der meldung dass die
flüge aus großbritannien die niederlande
einstellen dass wir eine situation haben
wir haben wir flüge eingestellt
bis dahin schien alles auf einem sehr
sehr guten weg
ich kann ihnen nichts ausschließen kann
ich nur sagen mit dem wissen von diesem
freitag vormittag bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich die vorletzte frage herr
inkl
ganz kurz nach vergangenen zum thema
johnson johnson sie haben freunde auf
die stiko verwiesen und haben gesagt
dass die keine einschränkungen
veranlasst habe in bezug auf die
empfehlung verstehe ich das richtig dass
es keine altersbeschränkung gibt wie bei
astrazeneca das verstehen sie richtig
verstanden nach der diskussion gestern
ist also dienste vor diskussion wir
erwarten heute zum beispiel noch mal
eine daten bewertung und präsentationen
in den usa bei dem entsprechenden
committee drsc die ergebnis kommen heute
raus und es wird eine weitere position
in der nächsten woche erfolgen auf basis
der neuen daten dann nochmal eine
bewertung vorzunehmen aber nochmal der
wichtige hinweis ist ja mädel raten
mäßig liegen die meldedaten nochmal 10
fach geringer bei jantzen
das heißt wir hatten aus den usa 8
meldungen zu sieben millionen impfungen
im übrigen weise noch mal wichtig ist
weil ich heute schon von kollegen
gesundheitsministern aus den ländern
natürlich auch gefragt worden wenn wir
haben eine bestehende empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission für den
impfstoff johnson johnson jansen und die
gilt dann die letzte frage richtet sich
an herrn seehofer und herrn schade
von markus am baarer ard mal angenommen
im herbst sind alle die wollen und
dürfen geimpft wird das reichen für eine
herdenimmunität bei der wirksamkeit der
aktuellen und kommenden impfstoffe wie
viel normales leben ist dann möglich
ja ich kann gerne sagen dass von
vorentwürfen durchimpfungsraten so
schnell wie möglich erreichen
wir wissen schon dass es gedankenmodelle
gibt das auch das nicht sofort zu
völliger auflösung erregern führen kann
weil wir noch nicht genügend wissen wie
lange dauerte im schutz und wie weit ist
die transmission von giften auf andere
reduziert ich gehe davon aus dass große
erleichterung geben würde wenn das die
form also in diesem sinne würde ich
zustimmen das wort herren immunität ist
ja auch muss man erstmal sich überlegen
was das bedeutet also eine herren
immunität in dem sinne dass das virus
dann weg ist also dass jeder steril
immun ist von den geimpften und wir eine
impfquote erreichen dass das virus nicht
mehr zirkuliert das glaube ich nicht
dass wir das erreichen wir werden eine
hintergrund immunität in der bevölkerung
aufbauen nach und nach und je mehr desto
besser
das auf jeden fall die geimpften und
dass die virus zirkulation deutlich
verringern wird
wir werden aber auch weiter gruppen
haben die eben nicht geimpft werden
können das sind zunächst erstmal die für
die noch keine zugelassene impfung da
ist wir werden andere gruppen haben die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen und wir
werden drittens gruppen haben wo die
impfung vielleicht teilweise andere
grunderkrankungen haben nicht den
erwünschten effekt gibt sodass doch auch
noch weiter gewisse virus transmission
sein wird die werden wir dann in kauf
nehmen müssen
aber das infektionsgeschehen insgesamt
wird deutlich geringer sein jeder wird
die möglichkeit haben sich individuell
zu schützen so dass dann eine situation
entsteht wie wir sie auch für viele
andere erkrankungen ja erkennen also
nicht jeder ist geschützt trotzdem gibt
es keine zirkulation man muss vielleicht
die impfung dann auch noch mal
auffrischen von zeit zu zeit und man
muss die nachwachsenden oder
neugeborenen jahrgänge nicht die
neugeborenen selbst aber die junge
menschen dann nach impfen damit die auch
die chance haben immun zu werden aber
ich gehe schon davon aus dass wir auch
weiterhin diesem jahr und auch in den
folgenden jahren dieses virus kennen
werden dass sich das etabliert als ein
virus das es in deutschland gibt das
vielleicht auch eine saisonalität hat
das aber dann in den auswirkungen wenn
wir eine grundimmunisierung haben so
würde ich das jetzt wie beenden wollen
eine grundimmunisierung sehr sehr viel
milder sein wird mit der wir dann
umgehen können nicht nur ganz kurz noch
ergänzen darf deswegen ist es ja auch
wichtig dass wir nicht nur impfstoffe
entwickeln sondern auch als name weil es
immer menschen gibt die erstens nicht
geimpft werden können die zweitens
vielleicht nicht geben finden wollen
oder wo drittens der impfschutz dann
auch nicht 100 prozent war sondern eben
die 90% deswegen werden wir jetzt ja
noch mal wie in der bundesregierung und
dank des bundestages jetzt mit dem
nachtragshaushalt der gerade eben
abgestimmt wurde dann auch unterlegt 300
millionen euro zusätzlich zu den bereits
bestehenden förderprogrammen in kobe 19
19 wick lung geben können vor allem für
phase 2 b 3 und produktionsaufbau also
diejenigen die auch schon weiter
entwickelt sind und das zweite ist und
das ist dann was für die künftigen
diskussionen
das wären dann noch gesellschaftlich das
ist das was ich schon bei geimpft nicht
geimpft andeutet dass werden noch ein
paar wochen wo wir immer wieder auch
diskussionen haben werden die dann
sozusagen in sich tragen wenn man nicht
gut aufeinander aufpassen auch das
potenzial zur spaltung oder zumindest da
so dass es auch ein bisschen hoch
hergeht
weil die einen im games sind die anderen
noch nicht und wir dabei noch nichts zu
null ausschließen können selbst wenn die
20 und alle 20er und 30er jahre gegen
noch nicht geimpft sind alle darüber
schon gibt es ja einige die sagen ja
dann sind die älteren ja geschützt kann
nichts mehr passieren aber
logischerweise wenn zehn millionen
30-jährige gleichzeitig infiziert sind
ergibt sich statistisch auch daraus ein
hoher handlungsbedarf
und deswegen gibt es so eine
übergangsphase von einigen wochen
monaten vielleicht wo wir beschränkungen
werden deutlich reduzieren können aber
noch nicht ganz bei null haben
und die müssen wir miteinander noch
definieren das wird auch noch manche
diskussionen bringen
manche diskussion die auch unbedingt
kontrovers sein soll
um das noch mal zu sagen wir am ende
immer so einer entscheidung führen muss
in der abwägung und nicht auseinander
führen sollte dann sind die fragen für
heute beantwortet vielen dank an unsere
gäste nächste woche gibt's bestimmt neue
fragen und wir freuen uns wenn sie
wiederkommen bis dahin tschüss